1940 we were on the gold standard you
couldn't really manipulate that much you
were still protected by the gold
standard as much as you wanted to
manipulate you know and kind of play the
game you couldn't fully you could do it
don't get me wrong Joseph Kennedy
mastered it in 20s and he caused the
whole 1929. all that stuff fine but you
still had a certain level of the FED
still had a certain level of
accountability to what they could do and
what they couldn't do Post you know
1972-73 gold standard were off of a
Nixon whether you agree with it or not
you know to where we are today today
these guys have more levers to control
and manipulate and play with than ever
before they're like yeah you know what
we're going to kind of go like this yeah
we're kind of gonna go go like this like
the whole thing with the default like
you know could we really default back in
the days every time we wanted to spend
something and this is this is like a
little over 100 years ago you have to
avoid it you know reported line by line
then all of a sudden it becomes what no
let's just let's just increase the debt
limit and let us do whatever we want to
do with the money because we need it and
you know what now we make it political
now it becomes divisives I think they
have so many different things to
manipulate to put temporary Band-Aids on
a catastrophic event that they could
delay that each time you're like yeah
they delayed it for five more years yeah
they delayed it for 10 more years do you
agree or do you disagree with the fact
that they have more manipulation today
than before oh absolutely and I want to
be clear I'm not saying that there's a
high probability that they default if we
even if you know if we go to this debt
ceilings I think that's going to be
resolved uh for sure isn't it always
resolved yeah yeah it's almost I'm less
concerned about the default we'll get
into that story I'm more concerned about
15 unemployment q1 of 2024. yeah but so
what you're saying is what Jerome Powell
is saying is that hey I've got the tools
for this yeah right well okay did he
have the tools for Silicon Valley Bank
he came out and created that new uh
facility I forgot what it's called the
bank fund lending facility or something
like that uh but then what do we have
then we had First Republic you see what
happens every single time they come out
and say that I've got a tool for you
know we've got the tools don't worry
Adam we've got the tools but the food
then you have another spank blob say oh
well I'm actually got to create more
tools but it was but it was because
they're always behind the insured though
it was to protect the the positive
deposit or not the no they never said
they're going to protect the Investment
Bank no equity holder is kind of wiped
out no no the the feds set up a a
facility so that those Banks could
unload those assets off their balance
sheet at 100 cents on the dollar well
they could borrow against it they
couldn't unload them they could borrow
against them at 100 yeah but they would
have to repay the loan yeah it's not all
floating but well if they had a deposit
flight they could get those assets they
could get 100 cents on the dollar they
could borrow 100 cents on the dollar for
the face value of those assets correct
which they thought was their problem but
then you had First Republic or it didn't
solve that problem so what I'm saying is
the Fed thinks they can solve these
problems but but they're way behind the
curve and if they weren't behind the
curve they wouldn't have to do 45 rounds
of quantitative easing as an example you
know that's an example another tool it
just had to do over and over and over
again well if it's so powerful why do
they have to do it 45 times and if
they've got all the tools for this why
do we still have these blow-ups when
they have to create another tool
you see the problem here is the the
global monetary system is broken
and if you if it wasn't broken you
wouldn't have a Silicon Valley Bank you
know why couldn't they go to the
discount window why couldn't they go to
the repo Market why couldn't they use
all of these free market solution well
not the discount window but the repo
Market why couldn't they use these free
market Solutions where the other Banks
would give them the liquidity they need
because there's too much counterparty
risk in the system because all the
banksters know that the system's broken
and the only person that's willing to
come in and clean up the mess is JP
Morgan if they unload the risk of the
asset side of the balance sheet they're
incorporating onto the taxpayer and they
say oh by the way in order for us to do
this deal we're going to have to borrow
50 billion dollars from the taxpayer and
I don't know if you read that story but
they took an immediate gain of 2.6
million and they're projected to make
500 million dollars a year on that deal
JP Morgan is and he didn't even have any
out-of-pocket cost to do the deal and he
said FDIC you've got to insure 80
percent of the losses that I incur if I
absorb this balance sheet I mean it's
just like it's it's a freebie but you
see my point but FDIC assistant it's
sdi's FDIC assisted rescue packages
which means the taxpayer is funding
assisting JPMorgan in the bigger banks
in rescuing the smaller Banks that's
what that's all it is oh rescuing not
rescuing
yeah taking taking over but that goes
back to my question though that goes
back to my question that they will use
every lever today because there is no
accountability to manipulate any data
point they want that's what I'm saying
yeah so you go back to covid yeah and
everyone said what you're saying is that
there's a fed put there's a fed put
George so we shouldn't worry about it
because they can kick the can further
down the road that's the argument that's
what seems to be happening that in covid
you could see that the fed put expired
because the FED tried to come in with
their put and the market kept crashing
it just said you know what the FED puts
done how long did it crash though what
was it probably a week
but it kept crashing until the
government came out that's the point
where okay so then we go from a a fed
put to a government put so the question
now becomes can the government act the
same way that the uh fed did and if we
are in an environment where inflation is
zero percent or they're worried about
deflation the answer would most likely
be yes assuming that the Democrats and
the Republicans could get along who
knows right but if we're in an
environment where inflation is extremely
high you know is the public going to
have the stomach for the Biden or any
Administration to come out and say yes
we're going to do another 5 trillion
when they realize that that 5 trillion
created this inflation that they're
having to suffer through now you think
the Public's going to say no to it you
think the Public's going to say no to it
they're going to say yes they're going
to open up their arms I mean it's not
look this is why the the system that we
have in America in a way it's broken
because there's no such thing as earning
the right to vote anybody if you allow
the majority to vote this was a republic
gradually he's becoming more of a
democracy where the individual is not
protected from the majority it's a
complete different concept of what
America was truly founded for that's my
concern my concern is
there is way too many levers to
the real economy and put a big ass
Band-Aid so everybody thinks oh things
are great guys let's go ahead and get
reelected like even before midterms what
happened pre-mid terms uh let's use our
uh all the stuff that we've been having
for oil and all that in our Reserve guys
dump it dump it dude use all of it use
all of it yeah
six dollars five dollars and fifty cents
five dollars 450. did you notice how in
the last midterms it's supposed to be a
red wave boom it's not what happened
well we fixed the economy a month later
back to the same again so the the
point I'm trying to make to you isn't I
disagree with you I think we should be
at 15 I think the mess that we have
should be a 15 out of the system but but
we have created zero George zero
accountability where we allowed these
guys to get away with murder because
whoever controls the knob controls what
they can do to delay the current issue
that's my concern we're aligned on the
same page I'm worried
remember before the elections there was
the recession and then the definition of
recession was two two quarters yeah
but then they had three quarters and
then they said no no but that's not
that's not a recession that's not the
definition of realization it's okay give
us what the definition of a recession is
well that's not the definition of
recession that that was the manipulation
yeah the other big manipulation is
marking not having to Mark T balls to
Market in other words not you know when
the interest rate goes up not having to
reduce the value of your holding on your
balance sheet if you're holding
government treasury rules all right
mortgage background or more good-backed
Securities what that means is that it's
that is manipulation that is as if
you're if I buy a property today and I
buy the property today for a million
dollars and then the interest rate goes
up and the property is only worth six
hundred thousand dollars if I say that
I'm going to hold the property until the
end of the mortgage then you don't have
to write it down and that's manipulation
because you don't know as a bank when
you're when you're when your depositors
are going to want their money back and
when that happens you're gonna have to
sell these mortgage-backed Securities or
these tables to honor that yeah and so
the biggest manipulation and the biggest
scam was not having to Mark these things
down basically a counting trip really
we're able to put an account called hold
to maturity is is what he's referring to
yeah it is a very good point all they
had to do was say we're gonna hold these
t-balls to maturity and you could write
them at the value of maturity
even though the value had decreased by
40 percent so a million dollar table if
you held a million dollar table for 10
years
it was on your balance sheet at one
million dollars even though if you want
to sell it in the open market today you
would get six or seven hundred thousand
dollars for it um
because you said you were going to hold
it to maturity but if your depositors
came and knocked in the door and said we
want our deposits back well you only got
600 000 you're gonna sell it that is the
manipulation yeah and that's why the
facility correct 100 can I ask you guys
a question and this is kind of to Pat's
Point let me just be clear about the
question
you're basically saying the system's
broken we gotta would you say End the
Fed over here Pat's basically like
saying somebody needs to be the bad guy
we're almost on a steroid or a heroin
trip right now right now yeah we're
inflating the economy my question is we
know that the administration whether
it's the current uh Democratic
Administration under Biden or whether
it's Trump they don't want to be the bad
guy because why they'll not get
reelected after the election cycle so
who needs to be the bad guy to get us
out of this mess is if the system is
broken is it the FED is it the secretary
who is it going to be I think it goes
back to Pat's Point uh that usually the
way these things end is just slowly and
gradually uh the politicians try to kind
of Dodge responsibility and the people
that end up holding the bag or the poor
and middle class and that's what's very
because if you go through what Pat is
saying okay they come out with more
fiscal that kicks the can down the road
but that doesn't mean that it fixes the
economy every economy continues to get
worse because as an example if you go
back to to purchasing power right we
have had nominal wages go up but if you
look at the actual real wages since 2019
they've gone down so when you adjust for
inflation yeah they're getting destroyed
that's right so we're eliminating Middle
America even though you get these stemi
checks let's say they do Ubi next yeah
right to try to fix the problem well yes
I agree with you that the poor middle
class are going to say yeah let's take
that let's take that let's take that I
think but unfortunately it's going to
make them worse off over the long run
because they're always the ones going to
pay them but if you're making 40 50
Grand a year and someone wants to send
you money you're never going to say no
we have the same conversation with
Andrew Yang but you know you know what's
crazy let me tell you yeah so so so
let's talk as capitalist here okay who
have have one somewhat won the business
game we're doing okay for ourselves
right okay there's a community that'll
say well that's easy for you to say
because you made your money and now you
got all the money and you want them to
go because you want to see the market
crash and all this other stuff because
that's how you're going to make the
money first of all a true free market
capitalist is going to do good in a good
Market a bad Market a terror it doesn't
matter they're going to excel so if you
print more money and you send five
trillion dollars through the economy I'm
gonna make money why because low and
middle income families don't know how to
spend money still comes to us yeah if
you don't give the money and you hold
these politicians accountable we're
going to go through a season where all
the fake capitalists are going to be
filtered out and they're going to go out
and work for a true capitalist and then
we're going to have some real people
that are doing it the right way operate
companies and then people are going to
say I want to work there I want to work
there quite frankly all these banks that
are going out of business you buy
long-term 64 63 percent of your assets
are sitting in that and rates are being
called in a JP Morgan sitting on 14
whatever their numbers was 14 15 some of
you guys are playing the risky game and
guess what you shouldn't be in business
there's guys that should be out of
business so for those that fall into
this trap of all the rich people want
the recession to it nobody wants to
recession to it nobody wants to money to
be printed we simply want accountability
accountability gets rid of fake players
in the game there's way too many fake
players in this game and nobody knows
who's who you're not gonna get
accountability because I'm going to
explain to you how it works I live in in
South Africa in South Africa we used to
have a reasonable economy today we have
10 hours a day of no electricity okay
you have to understand we have 10 hours
a day every single day where the
government switches off electricity on a
schedule so you get 10 hours that have
no electricity for everyone across the
country across the country 10 hours a
day whether you're a rich poor middle
income they just shut down they say Fort
Lauderdale bang they shut down Fort
Lauderdale has gone from two to six are
you listening now you think that you
think okay you think that's cool like
okay so the studio doesn't have lots so
you don't have lats the traffic lights
don't work which means that the traffic
becomes you can't go to a meeting
because there's no traffic lights the
store those can't operate so now you're
asking for accountability let me tell
you how this happens there's no
accountability it just gets worse and
worse and worse and worse and worse for
the middle and lower class until
something breaks when something breaks
how does the government respond
more money just makes it rain what
happens to the more money
close to the top we have a period like
covert where everyone has more money
yeah the the the the the people that
don't know how to save the ones that
aren't capitalists the ones that aren't
successful spend all their money and the
cream Rises higher to the top and the
people that are successful rise to that
top so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
thank you